yeah nathan tonight i'm here with you
thank you john thank you alex the 95 has
been closed for a couple of hours now by
a fatal crash
northbound or westbound at decatur and
you can see it's backed up all the way
through the spaghetti bowl
it's backed up to charleston so from
charleston
on the 95 through the spaghetti bowl all
the way to decatur
is a parking lot here's what happened
nhp has confirmed
a fatal rollover crash but that's not
exactly how it went
here's the photo as tweeted out by the
nhp and here's the story related by nhp
trooper travis maca
this black jaguar had a single vehicle
rollover about four o'clock this morning
but both of the women inside that rolled
over vehicle
survived and were helped out by a good
samaritan
for whatever reason the women decided to
go back to the vehicle
and that's when they were struck by this
pickup truck
so initially surviving a rollover crash
to be struck and killed by an oncoming
pickup truck
we know the passenger the jaguar died
the driver the jaguar is hospitalized
the driver of the pickup truck
is hospitalized but the bottom line for
drivers is
this parking lot now this is the
southbound side you're doing fine
this is the crash scene this is the
northbound side these are folks who are
getting back onto the 95.
here's what we're talking about the
detour you're being diverted off at
valley view along the frontage road and
here's exactly what that means
and the backups oh yeah all the way back
to the spaghetti bowl